everybody in this country should learn
how to program a computer
should learn a computer language because
it teaches you how to think
gradually over time i have learned that
i think differently from other people
what came as an even bigger shock though
was learning just how differently
everyone else thought from each other me
i tend to narrate nearly everything i
see and think in my head
i have a constant internal monologue
which mostly chats nonsense
but occasionally helps me to have a
really interesting new idea
turns out that some people don't have a
monologue like that at all
they simply know what they think or what
they're going to do no inner voice
necessary
likewise while i might memorize a room
by storing a mental snapshot of it
a friend of mine instead memorizes rooms
by learning the positions of the items
and where they are in relation to one
another like a set of instructions or an
associative array
the interesting thing here's a
mathematician and a pilot
i'm a writer and a programmer chances
are that our careers have completely
reshaped our brains the way we think
and the way we experience the world and
by taking up new hobbies you can
and should do the same i know at least
two people who read maps for fun they
actually experienced those places as
though they were there
one of my dearest friends who is sadly
no longer with us he used to read sheet
music and actually hear it as he did
that friend studied music at university
and played the flute at the highest
level
along with several other instruments
whereas i consider myself pretty good at
creative problem solving and ideation
he was just a thousand times sharper he
could do those same things in an instant
whereas i took much longer to get to
those same conclusions
any tracker that's a free runner is
likewise familiar with the experience of
parkour vision
where they actually see potential paths
to climb or jump across as they wander
through the environment
the brain is so incredibly plastic and
changeable that it's possible to remove
an entire hemisphere in a procedure
called the hemispherectomy and to still
retain the majority of cognitive
function
our brain regions can actually take on
the roles of other brain areas when
necessary
altering the way we process information
the primary role of this plasticity
that is to adapt to any given
environment the brain doesn't waste
space it won't become cleverer or
sharper than it needs to be
it simply adapts to the demands that we
place on it
change the environment change the
organism
the environment determines brain
functions and thus brain regions that we
use most often
this in turn can alter the way that
those areas work and can actually cause
those regions to grow and change shape
this then alters the way that we
approach subsequent tasks
in one study it was found that pro
athletes relied less on their visual
cortices
when rotating shapes mentally and more
on their kinesthetic senses as compared
to non-athletes
but what other activities can we and
should we engage in in order to reap the
most impressive cognitive benefits
i personally believe that much of the
success i've had as an entrepreneur
is the result of two things that i spent
a large amount of time doing
programming and writing that's because
writing is very much an activity that
utilizes the frontal regions of the
brain
higher order thinking writing requires
you to be focused but it also requires
creativity forwards planning
organization and logic
it also requires you to draw on a large
vocabulary and to work within the
structures of grammar
it even develops a theory of mind as you
consider how your words will be
interpreted
by a reader in one study conducted by a
german research team led by martin lotz
it was found that writers used different
parts of their brain depending on their
experience level
and the type of writing they were doing
a writer will engage their visual cortex
motor regions and related brain regions
even before they sit down to write
literally seeing what it is they want to
describe
however more experienced writers also
utilize brain regions associated with
speech
broca's area and wernicke's area the
hypothesis is that they are visualizing
a situation
while simultaneously narrating it it's
been postulated that writers eventually
begin to narrate much more of what they
do
which may at least partly explain the
constant chattering that goes on inside
my head
and to extrapolate this could also
provide other benefits offering a useful
way to step back and perceive a
situation in a more detached manner
as seen in exercises such as cbt this
could be one of the therapeutic benefits
of keeping a journal
one fascinating study demonstrates this
beautifully here a chimpanzee called
shiba was offered two plates of food
a large one and a small one if sheba
pointed to the smaller tray
she would be given the larger tray as a
reward while shiva was capable of
understanding the game
she couldn't overcome her instinct to
point to the larger plate however when
the plates were replaced with numerals
she was able to successfully play the
game by detaching herself from the
situation
what's really interesting is that
language provides an additional layer of
abstraction
on top of our physical reality it
provides a tool for manipulating more
information than we can purely through
visualization alone
this then helps us to think ahead and to
imagine possible outcomes
to have unique ideas and to solve
problems in creative ways
but programming takes this one step
further programming adds an additional
layer of abstraction on top of that
when we program we are speaking to the
computer in a language that allows us to
shuttle data around a series of circuits
and switches
in order to bring to life an app the
programming language allows us to meet
the computer halfway by talking in a
language that is somewhere between
english and the machine code that it
understands it's truly amazing that the
human brain is capable of doing this
using symbols extends the power of your
thoughts exponentially
another study demonstrates this here
chimpanzees learn to use plastic tags to
represent sameness and difference
only once the chimpanzees understood the
symbolic representation
could they then grapple with higher
order relationships for instance they
could now understand
that two pairs cup cup and shoe cup were
different from one another
philosopher andy clark stated experience
with external tags and labels
thus enables the brain itself to solve
problems whose level of complexity and
abstraction
would otherwise leave us baffled i've
been programming since i was six and for
the past ten years i've been writing
over ten thousand words a day
five days a week is it any wonder that i
lie awake thinking about things like the
nature of thought and new directions i
could take my online business
whilst many of my friends just don't
that's not to say that any one mode of
thinking is better than another there
are plenty of things they're better at
than i am
but these practices have benefited me
tremendously and i genuinely think that
anyone could benefit from incorporating
them into their own lifestyles
and in fact that is actually my point in
order to have a diverse and powerful
brain
we should practice using our grain
matter in a number of different ways
if you don't fancy programming then
another great way to think logically in
abstraction is to learn math or even
theoretical physics
this is easier to do than ever thanks to
apps like brilliant think about people
you admire and the skills you could
benefit from and then consider what
activities can help you to think that
way
if i should want to become a little
quicker-witted then i might consider
taking up music again like my sharp
friend
a study published in neuropsychologica
found that experienced musicians
performed significantly better on both
the strooptask and simon task
this suggests faster and more efficient
processing
it's worth noting that the way you
practice these tasks also plays a big
role
i shied away from sight reading and
preferred rote learning i imagine the
processing benefits would come more from
sight reading complex sheet music
quickly
likewise choosing which programming
language to learn could have profound
effects on the way your brain is
subsequently reshaped
learning an object-oriented programming
language like java for example
will have very different effects on your
brain as compared with procedural
languages
such as basic because the structure is
different and did you know that
programming styles are so idiosyncratic
and unique to the individual
that it's actually possible to identify
a coder by the way they program
this is called stellometry if you want
to learn programming stay tuned as i'll
be sharing some advice on how to get
started over on my blog shortly
this is a channel about fitness and
optimal human performance to me
fitness should extend far beyond squats
and running if you want to be the best
version of yourself
challenge your mind as well as your body
take up new practices hobbies and skills
and find that this can dramatically
alter what you're capable of i think
that regular writing and programming are
two
of the best practices that can benefit
anyone but they are just two examples
the most formidable intellect would be
someone with multiple skills who could
program write
build play beautiful music speak
multiple languages and perform amazing
feats of physicality
doing a few memory tests in an app is a
drop in the ocean but taking up
practices like this pursuing a
competitive sport or becoming a ravenous
reader
those things will transform your brain
in profound ways over time
i hope you found this video useful and
interesting guys if you did then please
share it around leave a like
that helps me out immensely and you know
what else builds your brain in an even
more fundamental sense
that would be movement and i'll be
exploring the effects of movement on
your brain
very soon so stay tuned for that one if
you enjoy this philosophical
alternative approach to training your
body and your mind then be sure to check
out my ebook and training program in the
description down below
super functional training it explains
how to train the body and mind
simultaneously
and it's currently on heavy discount
whilst many of us are stuck in lockdown
subscribe if you want more like this and
thanks a ton for watching bye for now